pas con truc si vous qui fait les
matches entre communautés ces derniers
de la saison
babet à un pouce bleus et puis
aujourd'hui on va faire un truc
différent va un petit peu suivre les
parties et on va commencer par les
petits lots en pensant que ça peut finir
plus vite
éventuellement et on va regarder the
bourbon king et de bourbon kid à l'ag en
vigueur de bourbon kid il te dira yahia
bourbon ya kid ya eu donc ça fait envie
de le regarder il est une capuche il a
une capuche il est qu'ils les capuches
et alors qu'est ce qui se passe avec the
bourbon qui ignorent iphone 4 le mec
fait des singles qui fait une
scandinaves ont le bourdon king il prend
lotfi kiev 6 il a fait crisser trois
lots tafer ces six heures il veut
vraiment donner le pion c'est vrai que
s'il avait joué des cadres du coup sûr
ses six il aurait pu peut-être essayer
de jouer les fous des 3 c3 et s'est
transposée dans une car aucun doute des
changes avec lecavalier en c3 à gap
récessif et d4 c'est pas top top elle à
l'autre il peut peut-être prendre de ces
faire céder le cas vaillance et 3 un peu
car dans les ouvertures à des quatre
dessins qui n'est pas très bien placé on
pourra leur place et vers deux jets 3 au
cas où on va voir
saad hassar est plus obligé de prendre
le pion à bâle a aussi ça fait papa sans
ça on va prendre en russie du coup et
c'est un peu bizarre de me prendre ces
six sur six d'ailleurs il prend l on va
faire des quatre mais le truc
le truc c'est que le car ayant ces trois
on voit qu'il n'est pas très bien placé
à la rigueur avec 6,6 y avoir du
développement d'un mois je fais pas tant
de faire food et royal 3 pour bloquer le
fou c'est 8 vous mes seins nus coup pas
idiot alors est ce que ça va faire fou
17 pour des clous et ça pourrait être
logique
alors on peut jouer rock avec l'idée que
si fait aussi du coup le le fou sort pas
de la chaîne de pions alors ça ça peut
être par là dessus on peut faire rock
après 2,6
on peut revenir en d3 allant peut-être
commencer par a3 histoire d'éviter les
québec 4 revenir en d3 avec le fouet
attaqué le roc noir
ça peut être un projet ça peut être
intéressant en tout cas c'est loin
d'être idiot ça c'est sûr donc je
bourbon kid qui a une position
intéressante pour le moment rafou pacs
casse la tête l'un de toute façon n'est
pas grand-chose à faire d'autre que rock
un ici blancpain on peut commencer
parfois f4 quoi mais ça semble pas
changer grand chose
j'ai l'impression que c'est que c'est
bien voilà il fait rock
ils arrêtent à tour en vain à russin 45
c'est surprenant l'agrément war is right
sur pions prend cavalli prend qui peut
être un type eau qui existent de temps
en temps là il marche pas parce que
quand on prend des sacs ont fait
reprendre du cavalier aulas étonnant le
5 tours en s'étonnant hausse qui peut
gagner un pion d'un coup ils pouvaient
prendre ici donc vous qu'il prend le 5e
marché pas fallu jouer un coup de
cavaliers on va dire ici et il pouvait
prendre un deuxième pion or là c'est
dommage c'est dommage parce que fait the
bourbon kid las de bourbon qui rate un
pion un quoi les taignons sarre compte
les arénas francophones à la semaine
prochaine étape
c'est sympa les annales francophone
c'est dommage hein
c'est dommage cette baisse a gagné une
partie en fait tu vois on peut jeter un
oeil peut-être une bonne nouvelle ça va
il a massacré massacre bonne nouvelle du
coup on prend la tête mène 1-0 pour le
moment et non s'est fait égaliser parce
qu'il ya le maître fide qui a gagné mais
bon on devrait dominer le match derrière
ça devrait pouvoir le faire donc il a
fait bouger 500 prend option des cinq 20
ans de bourbon kid
quel on peut prendre en prendre un f6 et
prendre des cinq peut-être peut-être une
grande mare entreprises f6 prises ici
prise des cinq prix f3 pressée 6 friis
et si ces prix de cette menace de
reprendre sur échec donc tu as trois
fuites qui est français si ce prix c'est
6 prise à froid et les blancs sont
complètement gagnant il ya un partout
pour le moment bref est prise et six
spéciales apprises des cinq voix c'est
bon ça c'est bon ça il va pouvoir gagner
au 4 avril et il est bien the bourbon
kid l on peut peut-être carrément
prendre 2 4 avec la tourelle c'est
fantastique là ça commence ça commence à
se dessiner pour the bourbon qu'il ça
commence à se dessiner allez on peut
aller voir française man qui joue contre
un maître fide grand maître pardon tu
vas précédente
je sais pas je connais pas trop
évidemment j'aime pas trop le foot et 3
mai à juillet ce qui lasse pas de 4,5
avec un joueur de 4 contre 3 qui va se
dessiner
demain crypte à la gagnerai c'est cool
mais si on se fait pas trop bouffé
devant ça va aller 1 derrière
franchement ça doit passer derrière
derrière on doit passer ce serait faut
vraiment qu'on va il faut les faucons
les battre car il faut pas qu'on soit
6000 il faut moins qu'on gagne un match
quoi histoire de remonter passé une
saison 2 qui on n'a pas fini dernier
c'est quand même mieux quoi c'est tu
vois sinon je fais la gueule quoi
j'ai cinq cas il peut peut-être mettre
le quart ayant aussi ce après il joue
pas mal française man mrta figli j'ai
planté une jolie tactique et bravo
tonton qu'elle a pouvoir s'y prend est
ce qui prend 2,6 prend 2 fc peut-être dû
dame g4 qui peut arriver qui sait je
pense pas que ce soit sa 18e prendre
prendre d'alger 4 bouffe voit la dame
est cuit 3m d'euros à eux deux fois f4f
un plan avoir un toit je n'ai pas la
science infuse mais ça peut peut-être
est une idée après il peut aussi prendre
parce que s'y prend du pion peut-être on
peut on peut jouer avec des saint
caprais plus tard un jour je remets le
petit lien pour toutes les explications
monette on est bien parti on mène 2 1 et
comme le disent et j'imagine que
derrière on va réussir à cartonner
alors comment continuer française man
alors surtout axé faire arnaquer on peut
aller voir sa nature sur carré d'art
comment s'est passée cette histoire pour
arthur tueur on va se passer la partie
en rapide voiture tuant resserrée qui
est plein de poésie dont le chat partir
d'un certain niveau c'est une cadence
qui est un petit peu dur à jouer sur
internet sur lequel une position tout à
fait correct j'ai passé ma vie à me
faire arnaquer dans cette cadence 1 j'ai
eu plein de positions un peu à la rue
arthur correct je me suis fait arnaquer
un nombre de fois considérable
par manque de concentration allemands il
était un peu moins bien après quand même
elle était un peu moins mais arthur sur
aia était moins bien ça versèrent là un
peu dominé quand même jour il faut
reconnaître c'est foutu pour arthur tués
dans l'est sont les défis jusqu'au bout
mais ça joue vite il reste 14 25 5 à 12
c'est un peu craignos arthur arthur
luc-arthur je vais pas rentrer sur sa
partie
yanis voilà un joueur algérien qui vient
qui a aidé la francophonie contre dogue
us bon ses pions isolé c'est pas clair
c'est chaud j'aime bien aller blanc mais
c'est compliqué et allonge est en deuil
une panne qui a les noirs ici
c'est sûrement pris une attaque de
minorités j'imagine on va regarder la
partie va jouer une slavia pris 2 ouais
c'est bien ce que je pensais à fos est
ici au f5 c'est important n'y a pas de
fonds et 5 fu g4 ici à il a mal joué à
ethan méthane qui comprend pas cette
position et annonceurs la non
compréhension des tannes frappante
il n'a pas sorti le fou de cases
blanches alors qu'ils avaient l'occasion
devenu fou et 5 fu g4 et du coup il
s'est pris la tête de minorités bep cap
des cinq thématiques n'y a pas d'
attaque sur le roi le plan agissent mal
placé parce qu'il empêche les tours ou
six tours à 6 le niveau de sueur d'état
n'a pas été assez mal placé pour les
noirs tout est assez mal placé
lee qui veulent arnaquer ouais c'est
dommage qu'ils aient tan n'est pas vrai
dans l'ouverture comme son adversaire a
pris il aurait pu mettre le foin f5 en
fête premier arrivé premier servi
prendre la diagonale ça lui aurait fait
gagner du temps vous mais manger 4 il
nous dit qu'il va attaquer ouais bon ce
possible après un nom c'est possible
qu'elle prendrait si j'aime pas trop là
par la der sar et anne qui a peut-être
pouvoir je n'ai pas à prendre est de
prendre à deux points c'est mieux que
moi
il prend des quatre où là j'aime pas du
tout la prise en d4
et puis on prend des cas depuis on prend
j'ai six tours angers 6 et c'est marre
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a pas pris en f2
je sais pas trop peut-être qui a perdu
kf4 maman il est mal qu'est ce qui se
passe à ans mène 4-1 qu'est ce qui se
passe on va retrouver voire un peu
france a on va revoir pour bryan en
bourbon pour bon kit qui va mater au
prochain donc ça ces bonnes nouvelles
bourbon king bim
samat française man l'homme qui joue la
française aille pas très bien mais pas
trop mal non plus pour le moment il est
sage ou encore mais the broom qui nous
ramène une grosse victoire
arthur tuerie va perdre
yanis qui a peut-être nous ramener la
victoire on mène 9-3 non on est bien on
est bien on l'est on les domine derrière
on l'est on les bouffes 20 meilleurs
cieux faire un truc à manger ou quoi tu
peux parce que ça peut être finir à me
tenir assez spécial si tu as besoin de
faire quelque chose d na vas-y tu veux
faire un thé ou quoi non mais tu as tu
veux faire un thé par exemple même même
moi tu vois je suis pas contre non mais
tu vas cela veut dire parce que sinon ça
va être spécial toi jusqu'à minuit diop
soutient maxime qui est venu sur le
stream hier bah tu connais maxime et
c'est que demain enfin meetup a été
abonnés tu viens avec nous pas tu sais
pas oui moi je te parle comme ça tu as
l'air en sueur l'ena mêlant sur mon mail
10,4 il proposait nul doute quelque part
je cherche un partenaire
bon ça c'est un chenil scrutin a ok
l'adversaire d'état n'est complètement
nul
l'adversaire dit anne est complètement
nul il a mis son pion à 7
ouais donc ça c'est nul maintenant allez
un p'tit coup de torah de la parfait et
ça je pense que ça c'est nul en touchant
à rien peut-être même mettre le pion on
peut peut-être même année puis jusqu'en
d2 pour éviter les rois bien et
compagnie je vais peut-être bien des 3
et d 2 9 patients ça fait une fois que
l'option des 2 h 5 j'aurais jamais joué
un roi jeu set et j'aurais attendu c'est
nul wi-lan qu'il a sauvé ces bonnes
nouvelles pour nous ces bonnes nouvelles
pour nous un oeil sur moi ici va faire
des deux c'est un peu risqué là ce qui
fait ce que des deux est ce qu'ils
payent à parois prend des en dames à
huit dames
alchemy sonore de vraiment eu l'air d'un
homme tour g8 sanon éprise prise à huit
dames échec 3g set j'aurais passé quand
même avec les noirs un truc comme ça
mais bon il peut pas y avoir de problème
la dame prenant avec adam protège le pur
h5 donc il ya rien c'est même peut-être
les noirs qui sont mis en règle faire
mieux
peut monter le roi à fond impression
fondre et le risque de la gagne et un
baiia d'ahmed trois-là et sa paire prise
prise et je pense que le roi noir peut
pas s'approcher des pions blancs parce
que le pion de l'anp va venir en f4 wave
3 f 5 oh là là quelle catastrophe
quelle catastrophe les amis et année
finale
or ils ne voient pas heureusement au à
vous me faites suer les mecs froid que
damas trois à gagner non non ça gagner
pas il y avait 3 g 5 h 4 non denses à
gagner pas f4 échec 3 et 4 ans ainsi
qu'à trois points ce qu'elle soit gagnée
pas là ils me font peur les mecs à vous
me faites peur allez là faut monter
droit les mac à un fois il cherchait le
pion
vous me faites peur
mais les arnaques à blain celle là
franchement elle est remarquable on mène
13 5 déjà non halal alors là on leur met
on leur met une raclée à lasser la
raclée la la c'est la raclée là les
turcophones 15,6 on y revient d'un peu
mais neuf points d'écart
fais attention pas faire rager 89,4
matin non mais ils repèrent la guerre
ouais non les parrains accable par
n'accable
ok mais ce que ça gagne on la regarde ça
gagne peut-être ça gagne peut-être droit
c'est 2 3 3 oui et non ça gagne je crois
que ça gagne
non mais c'est extraordinaire trois rois
des rois f2 et vous rapprochez trois
rangées de maintenant ça y va les gagner
c'est extraordinaire ils soudan est
complètement extraordinaire et à ethan
quel génie qu'est ce qu'il est nul qu on
adversaire c'est extraordinaire c'est
génial s'est essayée extraordinaire et
anne ce que tu viens de gagner
franchement tu étais un ce milieu-là
extraordinaire extraordinaire les la
turquie en sueur là il ya tous les turcs
qui sue à grosses gouttes ou en petit
roanne robe extraordinaire à c'est la
victoire qui change tout la balle et on
les écrase un y à 18,7 on les écrase un
franchement ohlala plus il a joué à 5g
talent qui va être en h4 l'enverront
extraordinaire des quatre aussi à moi
j'ai plutôt hk france elle a les mêmes
des 14 candidats avec le pion angers 5
issus complètement la ra les turcs la
bombe
les turcs construire c'est
extraordinaire oh là là y'a dame
français 5 olalalala veda russe en sueur
à son niveau de sueur après avoir perdu
cette finale mais il fut tellement à
grosses gouttes extraordinaire ok il a
pas mal joué là en fait en fait c'est
chaud si la tour prend à deux est un an
sur tours prend 1,2 et noir sont
gagnants olalalala et thain qui a joué
trop vite il se prend un contre hills où
sera ordinaire
aulas à état non sueur il ya joué trop
vite
il a joué trop vite ils ont su arman en
l'étalant sûr on va regarder un peu ce
qui se passe de l'autre côté bon j'aime
bien la position notre ami ianis l'ail
et bien ils attaquent le roi adverse et
cool
arthur tu rsa il joue bien c'est pauline
soullard sur thur arthur turle à mon
avis ces petits massages turc en
prévision française man française man tu
fais une bonne une bonne partie de
bourbon kid c'est la deuxième française
ne soit question c est ok 6 3 900 points
f7 pro f 7 foot rouaroua issifou des
deux fous ces quatre bouffe bouffe et
dames f4 hockey / fou prend à eux deux
il ya dam des deux et on peut pas sauver
la pièce que j'ai compris
bon c'est chaud donc rfr fouet trois
fous fous fous trois fois f2 est fou
c'est quatre machines à madame f 4 3
juin dame e3 et je pense est mort
dur on va perdre quelques parties la
nôtre et notre notre avantage va réduire
comme peau de chagrin mais et thann qui
a quand même gagné par abandon c'est
extraordinaire
thiessois fousséni abandon des noirs ça
j'ai jamais vu encore extraordinaire la
victoire des tannes j'ai pas compris
pour écouter
tant mieux on prend donc en fait on fait
ont très clairement l'écart et arthur
tueur peut-être un petit peu d'âme b5 un
machin on va voir française manne qui va
perdre
the bourbon kid on sait pas
permettant ainsi la cua
alzayani les deux parties 1 c c'est bien
vu et des propositions de nul 2 partout
crypte talent qui en a pas encore
regardé amis crypte al mithaq est proche
du 2-0 la grosse attaque son adversaire
en sueur je crois qu'on est en train de
leur marcher dessus
antoine 37 pas très bien antoine je suis
pas très confiant
pour bon qui est un peu sous pression
quand même l'assassinât ce matin c'est
quand le prochain match je vais te dire
germain je crois je crois qu'il commence
à 20h20 de mémoire là on est vraiment
bien en mains de 19,8 je pense je pense
pas qu'yves montand
qu'est-ce que ça sagan a un truc en
train de faire je suis pas sûr yanis
salut a href guy kg qui est nouveau ici
et vu bonjour mon avenir bonjour
il ya 20 à 10 parties c'est derrière un
faux fait jusqu'ici s'écoule pas tu
arrives et le charpentier charpentier
qui fait un genre de le système de
londres à la halle à simone williams
j'ai l'impression bon ça on peut
transposer en quelque sorte il va
peut-être jouer avec le rock tout cas
j'imagine
il a mis à d'alembert de base puis ça je
ne me verrais pas d'âme il faut comme ça
je pensais qu'il voulait jouer avec eux
il veut jouer avec ses 400 m une caisse
qui fait cavalier age ii il fait les
coûts bizarre charpentier cavalia je
sais cammas et on a ville aurait pu
envoyer de manière un peu plus direct
même ici à brax a perdu quelques tempo
et j'aurais pu faire bon à 3 déjà c'est
bizarre il n'aurait pas fallu faire dame
bernheim ces deux bons il peut quand
même joué grand roque
bon c'est un peu dommage alors fait à
trois bien sûr et envoyé direct après
faire un tour g1 et hk tâche 5 quoi tu
as toujours pas mal il a perdu pas mal
de tempo n'est quand même pas si mal à
mon avis mais un peu bizarre
ce probant qui se prend des propos de
nul 2 partout mais je bron qui aurait
peut-être mieux fait d'accepter ce que
j'ai pour les noirs ya agf jet tours
j'ai trois pions g3 d'alger 3 h un tour
à la fuite maths et j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu imparable d'action kg
madame proche de maths quand même est
obligé de prendre tous reprend au raf 2
j'ai même pas envie de regarder mais ça
doit être manager comme ça j'avais pas
envie de regarder de base donc objet de
prendre prix ça étoiles est un atout
right way
si son adversaire trouve ça assez mat
un tueur tuerie pas sûr qu'ils gagnent
au final crypte à lui par contre c'est
fini là c'est chaud charpentier c'est
chaud
un igloo ils peuvent un peu remonté faut
se méfier faut se méfier c'est pas gagné
il ya 23 13 et que 10 points d'écart et
j'ai l'impression qu'on a un peu fait
les points derrière mon pouvez les faire
et que maintenant il reste pas mal de
parties devant on n'est pas forcément
favoris ça peut ne pas être simple alors
the bourbon kidal et noir pardon j'avais
pas vu ça même d'habitude il me mêler
nos joueurs de la bonne couleur
excusez moi
donc en fait c'est notre joueur qui a
gagné oui bon ça ça fait plaisir du coup
on gagne 2,0 ici et là ça va ça va le
faire
ça va le faire
charpentier qui appelle tellement de
temps
ce serait cool de les battre si on gagne
deux matchs si on gagne deux matches sur
trois ça suffira
ça suffira pour l'emporter alors pour
finir devant eux au classement général
parce que je crois qu'ils n'ont pas
encore gagné un mini match de la saison
il ya quand même intérêt de les battre a
quand même intérêt de les battre
donc [ __ ] qui a gagné wayne rooney
l'ennui louga thiès il est érigé sans
une ride non selloum hausse puisqu'elle
hoummos voilà on est une pièce de plus
dans on va récupérer une qualité on
s'échauffe partout
on va pas louga du coup
bon
reviendra sur est sympa cette partie
diani ce genre algérien qui est venu
nous aider là est sympa les francophones
c'est vrai que la francophonie ça
représente tellement de pays quand tu y
penses tu pas encore un prochain match
aller prochain mais je suis à sortir des
ruines ce que tu prévient
j'avoue un pianiste va la perdre
jean pas quand on continue à attaquer
ici avec les blancs plus assez de pièces
attendant cette parade jouer remarque
adam g4 bien joué aussi
il est sous emprise mais adam projet de
mater sur g3 pour venir colmater cette
focus qui colmate avec jesse se rendre
une pièce c'est vrai quoi que quoique
quoique
m m la tour d lui allait tenter quelque
chose là au genre tour des huit dames g6
bouffe bouffe et tour c'est un et on
récupère un peu ça et on joue avec les
pions après ouais c'est pas idiot de
faire ça je pense va essayer de jouer un
truc dans cet esprit là mais tour des
miss paraît tellement logique quand même
ça ils le jouent d'ailleurs mais aussi
dame prend un chat avec la fourchette
derrière mais bon c'est vrai que tu fais
dame prend h 7 3 7 6 3 6 qui étrangers
quatre tours pranger 4 kw à genève 13
pas grand chose pour des 8 tu veux quand
même allés gagner le fou c'est 8 et tu
veut peut-être maintenant faire damage
cette cavalière 6 kg quatre étapes et
fut à la fin c'est chaud c'est pas si
clair encore cette position il ya nice
qui peut retourner le il peut retourner
le truc à nice
il peut retourner le truc arthur tueur
est un machin yanis et sa française man
ça va être dur mission n'est peut-être
pas mal ici c'est pas clair charpentier
il est bien à retourner sur yanis qui
réfléchit
ouais après je sais pas un set final il
a quand même que deux pions pour la
pièce j'ai pas à quel point
à quel point il est bien mais mais bon
ça se tente quoi il est mieux au temps
ci a pas trois fois tu vas perdre au
caire en métal je rate quelque chose
peut-être ya quelque chose que je vois
pas possible près possible
il est parti pour ce truc-là effet kf4
en premier bref tout ça me plaisait pas
trop j'avais peur qu'il la tour qui
revient dans g8 et ouais mais bon ça
doit aller quand j'ai huit tours c1 et
sur l'avs le football j'ai peut-être
disait kg 6 échecs a lieu sept
il ya toujours un f6
peut aussi avoir une idée qui prend
aussi c'est ce que j'allais dire et je
vais compte trois pièces mineurs est ce
si possible mais bon
je suis pas convaincu jours après
j'avais récupéré une pièce que de
rentrer là dedans
la tour seul il peut pas grand chose
trois pièces mineurs sont fortes et même
s'ils allaient pions normalement c'est
très difficile
normalement cette reddition la jeter un
oeil au score où ils vont même toujours
27 à 14 donc on peut se permettre d' un
peu perdre
faudra juste se laisse un petit matelas
pour pour les dernières parties du haut
du tableau
prévost qui essayait de rentrer dans un
fou cavaliers contre qu'entre roi arthur
ça donne quoi
par chance aucun accès à gagner un pion
grèce est très têtu et henri le pion à
intéressant
d'antoine qui est mal le charpentier qui
est toujours bien
proposition 2 nuls
je prends pas trop ce qui fait lâche 4
il se passe quoi je suis rage est tout
bêtement je comprends pas trop
bizarre pas craquer de partout
notre avantage fond attendez il a
récupéré une pièce ciani sort comment il
a fait ça avec tout bêtement le mec là
il s en est parfois un truc intéressant
c'est position à sept filets à tour de
rester contre le cavalier d'aller se
battre avec le roi parce que lecavalier
défend très mal sur deux elle
bon j'aurais pu tenter
le prendre le fou il peut tenter de
prendre le fou est allé jouer le truc
genre prise prise allait jouer le truc
qu'il veut mettre la tour angers7
ce qui est pas idiot
au-delà de ça que je montre est bien le
roi de l'autre côté antoine qui a réussi
à faire annuler
évidemment un très bon résultat vu sa
position est là le roi qui va venir
titiller les pions assez bizarre quand
il a joué mieux car il va perdre les
pions et sap a très bien joué la finale
c'est dommage
c'est très dommage pourquoi tuer les
écouteurs et rien entendu temps maximal
si le bruit des coups quand quelqu'un
joue bien bruits de coups j'aime bien
entendre c'est quand même plus pratique
on demande que l'on participe je vais
remettre le lien avec tous les toutes
les infos et puis si bien il ya nice
life c'est dommage
cette phase tourage 6 donner une plongée
3 et machin fr nul maintenant c'est
dommage je peux faire reprend ses six à
la bonne position joue autrement mais
entourant ces six pardon et ramener
laurence et 5 s'était pas c'était pas
super dur le score et commence à
remonter falloir faire très attention
tous comme vie et comme il reste les
gros lots et que devant ils sont un peu
favori ça peut retourner à mais arthur
arthur sur sa a faire nul ce quartier
chaque image prise g7 prix g7 prix g7 et
d'envoyer le pion mais c'est vers ça que
je dois faire d'amis en dameuse 5
donc ça ça à faire annuler il sacrifie
maintenant c'est pas si c'est encore bon
mais il aurait pu le faire avec les
pions f4 et j'ai trois ans vient
c'est peut-être encore pas mal c'est
peut-être encore pas mal mais bon là
même avec les purs f4 et g3 c'est quand
même c'est qu'à mieux en ayant encaissé
ces six encaissés à 6 on remettra il
faut avancer les pions et ça ça doit
être nul mais bon au moins y perdra pas
là samouraï c'est show arthur tueur
c'est nul
là on va voir la fin là c'est gagnant
que c'est cool on marque des points et
charpentier qui doit pouvoir prendre
cinq mètres la tour en c5 et c6 à la
tour qui arrive ans et si ça ça va faire
mal
il va de la paix les trois faiblesses
adverses alors ici comment on essaye de
beauce et peut-être des cinq pour
essayer de travailler à 5-3 bessette à
elle rend 17 est super bien placé et qui
s est je pense pas très bons coups parce
qu'il veut maintenant a6 a7 a8 est
généralement à ce niveau là c'est
difficile à défendre ses positions
on était fous de fer qui est des cinq
mais qui est des cinq à six qui est
prend des cats à 7
ouais il peut il peut ignorer la cni
cela gagne on maintient en dix points
qui fait ça on sait bien et maintenant à
six est pdci 3b 8 diagonale par rapport
aux cavaliers facile à roye b 8 comme
coûts et à cet arthur tuerie qui
essayent de sortir l'euro il peut pas
sortir des machins de toute façon ouais
et à 7
cette finale depuis elle est gagnante à
b5 b6 des sept des huit et c'est fini
l'histoire de yanis et peut tout près
move et d'ilisu formidable pincez moi on
va voir après ça c'est un gagnant
apparemment les 28 18 et non plus les
partis passent mieux c'est mieux c'est
pour nous encore des gens que tu leur
première partie un caucus cave
oui voilà c'est ça c'était ça là c'est
celle qu'on regarde et qui viennent
devenir la première partie et vient de
mettre un point pour nous donc on se
points d'avance et il reste y est
moindre en deux parties on a perdu une
quelque part sur thur machin vous pouvez
déjà aller vous inscrire pour le
deuxième tournoi
les charpentiers qui va sûrement la
gagne et ça fait peut-être même faire et
chaque échec en premier et après prendre
1 4 on peut dire encore de faire ça
yannis tafer nul arthur turquie a fait
nul l'houmeau ce qui va gagner
antoine c'est le bordel alors comment le
charpentier a fini elissa ben laden sans
la jouer mais peut-être que yanis avait
plus le temps d'aller voir tour à 6
tours macha mais ça on a encore on se
prend des carrés c'est cool on maintient
au maintien on maintient l'écart là il
n'ya plus aux parties il en reste une
ici le charpentier 2 3 4 5
il reste six parties donc on est bon les
mecs on a regardé on gagne ce premier
match haut la main les mecs
allez il manque qu'un match à gagner sur
deux et on gagne un match sur deux on
gagne un match sur deux et c'est fini on
gagne un match sur deux et on gagne
les variantes et droit arrive à monter
les tours a pris la montée les pions ça
le charpentier c'est gagné crois tu que
joue le blitz drôle de type
on n'a pas besoin de moi je la sens
comment l'art et n'a pas pas super bien
rendent hommage aujourd'hui j'ai fait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses du coup pas super bien mais bon
on verra c'est pas très grave juste plus
importante en ce moment on va tenter un
meilleur
mais bon y'a une planque arrivant des
cinq temps l'un des bons la reine on
peut le oui vous pouvez tous la reine
ben oui tout le monde peut y participer
c'est la reine du vendredi 1
bien évidemment on peut y participer
c'est même recommandé d'y participer
ça va gagner ça gagne vraiment facile
vous avez vu le stream hier sur la prod
chez sega et maxime qui est passé
c'était sympa l'asnl en coin non
invitons à nous dire que vous voyez
n'est pas avec moi à la wla d'arriver
chez lui quoi là donc on va le voir
d'hommes ceux qui sont sur canal ce cas
des gens qui m'ont répondu on va
regarder ça s il ya des gens qui vont
venir demain nous voir avec vlad de voir
ça voilà ça va gagner tout seul c'est
pour ça n'a pas grand chose a commenté
arrive à monter droit et les pions ça
devrait le faire
ça devrait gagner sans trop d'encombrés
on gagne on gagne vraiment sans encombre
la ce match au final match facile pour
nous ça gagne facile pour nous vraiment
très facile alors des bons quand même on
est quand même bon
un jour 17 17 la sagan tout seul le
charpentier en sueur et c'est de
l'intérêt j'espère le roi des huit baies
sept des huit dames et roye b 8 sur wade
8b sept des huit dames et / ou un v8 dé
sept des huit a et b 8 dames près move
et c'est gagné
aujourd'hui points d'avancé on va
remonter à 11 points
on a vraiment pris l'avantagé à ses 10
points d'avance rapidement début de
match il reste plus grand-chose double
poney qu'il ya une pièce de plus
complètement gagnant est donc en plus on
va bien finir super génial alors il a
les blancs salariale et noir ça doit
fermer mais ça peut ne pas être si
facile à moi ce qui est déjà un père
pète force et je crois qu'il ya père
fait rage et 8 d'am-dam huit mois et il
a quoi que encore ouvrage c'est un match
ici ça c'est ridicule de la langue ok
c'est pas si ridicule d'un mach 5
ce que l'hôte avant il a fait nul par
émission et je crois pas qu'il ait pu
s'échapper alors on a perdu il reste
française rem est bon même si on a perdu
on reste avec un grand avantage quoi je
suis assez de partie pour perdre
on venait que peut-être faire tourner
ses six ans et complètement gagnera rien
à rien a analysé en fait peut-être
rester sur française man tu joues contre
un grand maître vraiment fort et gagner
en cinq + 2
alors comment ça se passe bon faire une
petite petite sunny pause après prochain
match qui a démarré dans trente 30
minutes je vais aller regarder un peu
qui a ils sont beaucoup mieux classée
dans le prochain match ils vont être
plus forts que nous dans le prochain
match parce qu'ils n'ont pas de petits
lots m haies mais on est plus nombreux
et du coup je sois prêt disent que 500
va pas revenir là dessus mais là ils
sont plus nombreux ils sont plus forts
que nous devons d'abord besoin de moi
pour le blitz
on va voir plus fort en blitz
ils ont avec un classico que ça à faire
quoi française man qui est mal on verra
en verve sa part du monde qui va venir
pour le deuxième match tout cas on est
beaucoup plus nombreux que ça c'est une
évidence
ils ont quelques petits lots mais mais
pas assez quoi as tu es jolie la
combinaison apprend des cinq tours à
huit pattes
il ya des quotas
jolie combinaison final je sais pas si
le premier match est terminé je crois je
crois que je pourrais un match s'est
terminé avec ça et donc bah on va se
lancer sur le deuxième jeu mais pour
s'inscrire oui donc on est déjà plus
nombreux et on manque un peu de joueurs
bien classés
on manque un peu de joueurs bien classés
7 de baisse qui arrivera c'est commencer
à française man elle va falloir ramener
du lourd
enfin envoyer du lourd allions gagner un
match sur deux on est bon chez plus on
en est au classement jeter un oeil match
communauté alors espérer on va espérer
gagner allez les mecs défaut est chaud
fois de show les mecs mais c'est vrai
qu'on est pénalisé le fait d'être plus
nombreux et qu'on comprenne pas par
forfait derrière ça ne pénalise les mecs
ça nous pénalise dans les favoris sur
plein plein plein d'échiquier derrière
vraiment plein cryptage et au premier on
a 1000 sk les cryptes allait me laisse
obtiennent devant aller sa partie en
échoit long récit on va regarder crypte
talent ça va démarrer les mecs on va
suivre me laisse que j'ai jamais vu on
va le suivre 7 de baisse on va suivre et
anna l'on va suivre devant et on va
chercher louga ce qu on connaît pas son
ne sont
son lots à le gasc mais il nous a
demandé d'aller le voir mais je le vois
pas la fecq une bonne soirée je le vois
pas on va suivre cristal pour le moment
pour les prochains matchs demande le
changement de tempo à 5/6 ils veulent
plutôt allonger les cadences ou en tout
cas au moins les garder comme ça donc
j'ai déjà demandé arthur donc cristal
qui a fait quoi il a fait un gambit
evans a drôlement bien 27 ans l'italien
alors passé plus des bustes et
l'italienne et la fée b45 en billets 25
films plombée pour dévier le flou mais
gagner du temps développement au centre
c'est assez dangereux comme couverture
pour les noirs et c'est intéressant 1000
est qu'ils allaient noir de kéba nasa ok
bon pour avancer une espagnole
tranquille ou 7 de baisse 7 de baisse à
un maître fide ça lui fait pas peur
ça doit être ça une espagnole d'armes
des changes
donc est ce à ce jour et tan tan sim
quatre cavaliers voir passer la partie
tenkai et deux parties tout à l'heure il
est chaud et and mail ou la chiappa à
ses adversaires et qui cale aux terres
et la prie prie le connaître plus ou
moins et anne blanc ça va garder un oeil
aussi sur les scores très vite marque
allez on va retourner sur crypte talent
qui réfléchit dans son ensemble
ouverture
sakifo g4
puis on prend ici c'est show hilarant du
pion le malheureusement le truc avec le
fc 3 f 7 kg cinq dames g5 marche pas
puisque adam pranger 5e on n'arrive pas
à récupérer car le fou j'ai quatre cafés
fouet 4l qui ont appréhendé six iraniens
ou pas
sont ils vont encaisser des 6es va avoir
une position correcte c'est pas mal tout
ça pour le moment il ya un partout alors
où est ce que ça gagne on va les regards
n'est pas une bonne opération pour nous
c'est un partout au parlement c'est pas
écrit par faire sans une bonne opération
dans le sens où ce parti qui est évident
c'est plutôt les parties derrière et
c'est les parties où on est favoris aux
faucons marque parce que devant ils sont
bons donc du coup là en fait il se
retrouve avec un pion plus métier prend
1,4 du mime tu vas voir tout re 1 et qui
a et b d2 j'aime bien la position de
cryptage il m'a l'air pas mal cryptage à
grand roque j'avais pas vu ça
guillaume ont écrit fourchette royal à
la roue et il n'y en a fait cinq sages
avaient j'ai pensé tout en cherchant
guillaume que je ne trouve pas compliqué
c'est peut être y est vraiment partout
ce qui peut prendre f7 mais il ya
beaucoup d'activités pour les noirs
après j'ai pas trop d'avis clamé nasa et
ça c'est pas mal quand tu réussis avec
l'option b 3 généralement il est
peut-être pas mal me laisse qu
jamais en position de mme il est dommage
que le pion soit pas en c4 ce que la le
fourbe et 1 serait complètement fermé il
peut peut-être un jour repartir en d3
mais quand bien même bon c'est chaud
quand même hyper de la taxe sur le roi 7
de baisse d'à mambé 8,7 à marcel parent
peut être gênante m ça il va peut-être
mettre sa lavande b5 et b6 non plus mais
ça en bessin qui a joué c'est ce à quoi
hockey peut peut-être faire tour f1 dame
b 5 avec l'idée de faire ses cinq tours
tour ici mais forfait un garde de ne pas
se prendre un tour point f7 chaque fois
y aurait en fait quand tu fais c'est 5
et tour à 8h et tourcoing f7 ou l'autre
place saddam bien évidemment bien jouer
d'amitié très que ses choix avec le pion
white est pas forcément bien celle de
beast est annoncée palais on va
retourner sur la partie de grippe talent
je la sens pas trop j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu m
guillaume piens gagneur on mène 7-3 pour
le moment mais c'est normal qu'on mène
en début de match parce qu'on est plus
forts derrière mon avis ça va être serré
mais si on gagne c'est cool et à tour
total un peu moins bien il a une moins
bonne structure de pions il ya le foot
b6 qui tape sur f2 c'est un peu
dangereux et ne vais pas su être nouveau
12 abonnés à la chaîne fin de flo la
chaîne alors millassois le jour a pu
faire food est ce que j'ai en fait c'est
plus embêtant ckt le font bien il a faim
ma ville il peut faire food et 3 onces
étendue j'aime bien les noirs quand même
enfin quoique j'en sais rien je ne sais
pas mais j'aime bien les noirs mais j'en
sais rien à voir 9 5 est ce que tous
seraient toutes les parties ça joue
derrière c'est tous des partis qui ont
été jouées à l'arrière des noeuds
non c'est tendu kiev 6 il revient il
peut toujours mettre la tour en g8 et
tous et ouais mais c'est quand même
qu'ils essaient 4 me semble être
intéressant
semble être intéressant ph 5 qui va
partir vers f4 il ya la dame qui peut
arriver en h4
je devais appliquer on sait si ce n'est
qu'ainsi ci fera pas grand chose mais
très bien davantage 4 après la tour en a
huit
libéré après le car l'hiver f4 ça me
paraît être sympa non il est peut-être
bien mis la sks 6000 est ce que gagne
c'est vrai que ce serait cool si sur les
premiers échiquiers on peut ne pas
prendre ne pas prendre cher surtout
quête annexe gagnant avec les noirs s
michaël eytan qui mais je voulais rue
craignait alors elles craignent un
pourquoi est ce qu'ils jouent avec les
turcs on sait pas mais en tout cas il a
mis les turcs ont su lorsque sur qui on
prend il ya la dame prend échec rouaissi
et tour b6 j'imaginais leroi moore est y
avait probablement aussi d'en prendre
quatre y aller plus vite et là et anne
est inquiet à finir le boulot
donc ouais nan c'est cool on tient
devant du méthane qui a gagné on va pas
prendre
on va pas prendre la marée devant et ça
c'est la bonne nouvelle ça c'est très
bonne nouvelle pour nous si on prend pas
la marée devant derrière à mon avis ça
va faire le taf 14,8 toujours six points
d'avance crypte talent qui a cette
finale de foot couleurs opposées alors
finale foot couleurs opposées
le roi doit défendre du côté de la
minorité et le foot doit à doha a tenté
de défendre tous les pions il faut
mettre une bonne structure pour pouvoir
tout défendre
par ici comment il se confond à mettre
la structure
qui peut mettre à 4,5 g 4 et défendre
avec le fourrage 5 avec le roi de
l'autre côté
ça tient de faire ça
parce que quand le roi viendra le fou
viendra la haye en âge 5 lors attendra
de ce côté là on peut même la jouer avec
deux pions - il va attaquer les pions
carrément mais normalement je pense que
ça défend le truc que j'ai dit
bon
il échange une paire de pions avec ça
c'est complètement nul
mais juste il faut pas qu'ils parlent de
ce côté là avec le roi fallait mettre le
foin f3 et attendre même là bas en huit
le roi doit aller systématiquement côté
minorités non mais là ça va marcher mais
bon puisque à pouvoir faire rage et 6
encaissés le pion essayer de faire un
échange m'a charmé juste tu prends des
risques quand tu défends comme ça bon
même de 8 points
on mène de 8 points donc 98 points on
est bien
qu'elle a calé juste du projet 5 et
tuerait mais bon honnêtement il n'a pas
joué de la bonne manière quoi je serai
bien fou à vii l'a poussé à faire h4 et
je partir avec le roi défendent la font
vraiment repartir avec le roi c'est
vraiment pas la bonne manière que cris
talent a utilisé pour annuler sa îlots
régulière au stage à budapest il s'est
mis en difficulté tout seul donc l ars
oi détroit tu mets le rend bien et c'est
nul automatique sans adversaire du
fairway c3 pour espérer quelque chose là
laurent b 1 c'est nul automatique
vraiment les noirs peuvent rien faire le
fou navigue comme ça et c'est nul tout
de suite aïe aïe aïe la technique en
finale les amis font peu étudiée quoi
alors là c'est très chaud là on a pièce
de plus non la pièce de plus voilà c'est
très chaud celle de ben est alors à
temps cette baisse a les noirs et des
pions vont comme ça donc il va perdre et
anne avec les blancs mon avis il est pas
mal mais toujours que huit points
d'écart et comme je disais devant peut
se faire un peu rattrapé
donc il va falloir être vraiment très
méfiant s'est pas encore fait cripple ça
c'est nul nul total il suffit juste de
mettre x 3 x 8 x 3 x 8 et senior sales
qui tient à ces trois secondes par coup
ont pu c'est pas deux donc c'est très
simple il ya juste aucun risque pour
crystal michael faut pas prendre la
marée devant c'est ce qu'on disait on
n'est pas en train de l'apprendre donc
[Musique]
me laisse que qui est pas si mal
on va voir on va voir ce que ça va
donner mais à mon avis à mon avis ça
doit se doit gagner
à mon avis ce match doit gagner
peut-être faut tenter tour f 7 touafik
et prend h3 et jouer pour tout repart f3
jamais à tour arrive 7 pour éviter
l'essai 7 mais bon il éviter les des six
à l'efo faut espérer qu'ils le fassent
alors même 29 à sa 15 e l'aller c'est
bon on prend le large les parties devant
sont pas si mal passé et on a on a pris
le large
on va on va les battre et m les mecs les
mecs on devrait battre les turcs les
mecs à moins d'un truc gravissime
incroyable ou quoi les turcs sont sur
les turcs vont finir dernière de le
dernier de la compétition il va falloir
les battre en bullet pour qu'ils aient
marqué zéro pointé leur arme pour les
mettre en vrai sur par contre ça me
paraît un peu difficile pour miley sq
mais bon 14 points d'avance à y plante
le cheap au high la plant and cheap au
mais qui n'en est pas un
on me laisse qui va perdre 7 de best
avec les noirs qui va perdre donc on va
se faire un peu récupérer des points
le truc c'est que les parties devant
petit à petit elle seule elle se
terminait donc l'écart comme ils étaient
14 points s'est passé pas important quoi
les partis de derrière reste c'est parti
de derrière reste je l'atelier de
commencer le tournoi a pris
malheureusement avec un peu de retard la
reina ça va être difficile l'aréna
avec dix minutes de retard ça va être
compliqué ça va être compliqué ce soir
ça est très compliqué et elle va perdre
mais pas très bien quel talent
miley ce qui va peut-être prendre de
néant
cette de beast qui est un petit piège
jordan ses trois tours est fort trois
courts f3 échec
c'est un piège connu ça pour faire patte
tour ces huit là est née six mois et
maintenant ils menacent m'attends à 7
tours d83 aussi cessé matt torcé on va
un peu perdre devant madame g8
m'attendre mais bon ya 16 points d'écart
ils vont pas ils vont pas remonter les
mecs pas de panique pas de panique pas
de panique on perd un peu de vent mais
pas de panique et année ce qui va
pouvoir faire quelque chose vous me
l'envoie l'autre à reprendre du roi ya
peut-être eu un truc avec f5 bon cette
même fou des cinq échecs en premier f5
après avoir vu pas mal et annaëlle et
ben ouais il est bon sens qui suit la
chaîne l'industrie marais et f5
maintenant à s est bien mais on sent que
ça suit la chaîne bitstream assez bien
joué cette histoire de talent un
monsieur qui l'a fait un petit déception
est mais ça va on à +16 on à +16
monsieur p soir n'a plus 17
on a plus 17 franchement c'est pas
exactement où il reste deux parties mais
il doit pas en rester beaucoup plus de
20 tu vois cette 22-23 quoi à moins
catastrophe
on doit on doit le gagner ce match
surtout qui est à la tête gagné donc ça
ça va encore augmenter davantage
normalement ce match on l'a dans la
poche
ce match on a dans la poche des amis les
amis les turcs en sueur à ce plaisir
d'enfin gagner
il y en avait plein les couilles de
perdre et enfin on va gagner
est-ce que je chauffe pour l'aréna vas
tu as des lâches pas très chaud en plus
jeunes d'esprit mais deux heures avant
n'y a pas de pause et je vais commencer
avec dix minutes de retard
ça va être très difficile je te lave ou
mais on va tout donner
allez et and put 15 points d'avancé
c'est bon ça va le faire aller ilisu 13
points d'avancé 3-1 qu'intéresse à fond
comme neige au soleil l'a surtout qu'on
va peut perdre devant elle il faut pas
vraiment kettane la gagne les problèmes
de connexion c'est cette connexion quoi
cette fonction serveur tchatche.com
c'est pas grave on est en salles ferment
crypte al badil en sûr qu'elle va perdre
1000 est ce qu'on ne sait pas cette de
best on ne sait pas et il va peut-être
finir en force lors comprendre
comprendre tout reprend échec froid
prend tour elf un échec 3e set faut
juste 5 maquillage je pense ça gagne
comme ça de manière très primitive
ok donc l'autre à vue maintenant que tu
es primitivement prendre sont fous ces
primitifs qui va te faire [ __ ] en ici
c'est rimitti m'en fous j'ai cinq
primitif comme truc il voit tout et tu
auras des huit aidé à me prends des cinq
peut-être direct ils feront des six ap
non cette marche pas mais peut-être fou
et f4 ici madame prend des cinq ya tout
là matériellement il en y voyant une
menace tout reprend ses 6es fouet f4 et
matériellement il à 2,4 comme pour la
pièce bâton consiste à me prendre cinq
avants dont c'est fini malgré amayra le
joueur ukrainien évident mais cette
matin mais ça ça va aller aussi bas
c'est bien et annecy béquilles mais ces
deux points il fait du bien c'est là
donc devant se sera pas fait dominer de
fouet non je te faut faire un nouveau 44
et donc on a vu 14 points d'avance il
remonte un petit peu mais du coup
mécaniquement et de moins en moins deux
parties donc donc c'est pas grave de se
faire un peu remonter assez cool les
mecs rue grammont content là je suis
vraiment content parce qu'enfin enfin on
sera pas dernier tu vois on sera pas
dernier on ne sera pas dernier
allez pour le bullage vraiment encore le
mien je mets toujours le lien les amis
moi je vous le dit c'est officiel on
sera pas dernier on ne sera pas dernier
ça ça me fait vraiment plaisir
les turcs seront dernier les turcs
seront dernier mais nous on sera pas
dernier emmène toujours de plus 14 de
moins en moins deux parties la malaria
+14 parti c'est bon c'est la catastrophe
adac pour les turcs
ils ont recruté mitroglou les mecs ils
ont recruté mitroglu mitroglou et partir
en turquie et on bat les turcs
coïncidence je ne crois pas je ne crois
pas que ce soit une coïncidence les amis
je ne crois pas son mitroglou visée
parce que y'en le lien du las du live de
mvl wells et slash mvl chef et c'est la
vérité les amis les turcs tombe par
monsieur pessac doivent quitter un pour
l'aréna les turcs sont en train de
tomber le bosphore en sueur alors
laissons les amis cas où les mecs on a
plus l on les a mis k o
les turcs eux ko ko debout les touches
mvl chasse exactement je sais pas si ce
crime en anglais ou en français
d'ailleurs ouais ouais mais le thé parce
que toute façon il ne suis ni va y avoir
encore minimum deux heures de stringer
donc si on voit pas en fait rien on
débloque et un en anglais arrogamment
dommage mais les mecs qu'on les écrase
les amis d'arthur turckheim mahatma
finale ratant faut trouver arthur tueur
arthur turquie allait noir et qui va
gagner mais bêtement arthur turquie
marque
la suisse qui nous aident
attention le ski est pas une tour folle
attention il est dit la tour fois
l'acteur premier chèque et dames et
c'est bien joué
la suisse qui nous aident pas moi perso
je collerais bien des échecs pour les
encaisser sa tour fait formidable tour
une dame qui va s'approcher
dam des quatre de nam iv roi des indes
en d3 roisin dame e3 roi des huns je
prends ta tour et tu dégages
alors c'est bien les mecs d'amasha
facile aussi dame de france est un
et c'est fini arthur turquie a battu
sniper chess 50 à prendre deux frères
ont les massacres 53 53 32 la +21 les
mecs
franchement les bains en sifflotant
franchement fin faudra leur dire la
saison prochaine ce n'est pas la peine
qu'ils reviennent ainsi recrute pas
cessé on les explose à 1 face et là
c'est honnêtement il n'y a pas d'équipé
en face afin de dire là on montre notre
supériorité
car le monde est en sueur là on est en
train de montrer un niveau de
supériorité par rapport aux turcs qui
accueillent gens ils te dire
fêté hier la turquie en sueur
le monde est à nous et c'était une
chanson d'akena tonnes avec un field de
pas si ça le monde est à moi tu avais 53
32 c'est un massacre les amis c'est une
humiliation 55,32 +23 les mecs on lâche
rien ils sont tombés sur plus forts
qu'eux
cette baisse c'est ce qui va nous donner
la victoire à ils sont vraiment tombés
sur beaucoup plus fort que c'est clair
enfin le monde détaille le monde est à
nous le monde est à moi c'est pas ben ou
battantes on peut taper sur you tube tu
tapes akhenaton featuring pas si tu vas
voir il ya citron ya citron citron
chocolat
il est mal autant
bon allez on y va le 5 à faire tourner
cet aléa les citrons chocolat il est
chaud fantastique tour 17 quand même
bim bim bim bim citron chocolat qui met
humaine supéry 53 en sueur c'est gagner
les amis citron chocolat il a gagné les
amis alors on augmente les car ils ne
sont pas à notre hauteur les amis ils
n'ont pas le niveau pour pour s'opposer
à nous et ce qu'ils peuvent s'asseoir à
notre table ce soir et dire on joue
aussi bien en échec que vous est-ce que
les turcs peuvent s'asseoir à notre
table ce soir allez jouer au football
avec mitroglou les amis on a été plus
fort que vous et c'est la vérité
allez qui a aidé 5
on les a écrasés les amis allaient boom
dégagements ce pion c'est simple image 5
en l'espace lima trois à cache-cache moi
ce fou prend à trois dames ces trois
rails pas ça ça joue pas la tactique la
citron chocolat c'est trop chocolat qui
est un peu dans le rouge
qu'est-ce qui fait citron chocolat qui a
lâchement kiev 4 est aussi ça les batwa
estran chocolat à l'équipe iv sa
manoeuvre
je pense que c'est ça qui va se
faciliter la vie à l'e mail qui
enrichissent quand même moi je suis un
petit courage si ça a un petit coup de
dames f4 la voilà j'ai cinq dames et
fils d'un projet 5 et sur oise 5 g 4 en
1 h 4 dames g3 allez ça va gagner les
amis ma tendresse qui va avoir le match
en main ah ils le voient pas william
attend de la maj frat-mat après la
marche 3 matmat en arrêt lille avions
aux allées c'est fantastique c'est
fantastique c'est encore un point dans
notre escarcelle
il reste seize the best
c'est la dernière partie du match on a
plus 23
on les aura écrasé c'est vraiment le mot
les mecs écraser on les a écrabouillé
franchement ils ont été inexistants
franchement je me demande même et ce
qu'ils ont joué puisque enfin est ce
qu'il ya eu match ou pas y a pas eu
match les amis il n'y a pas eu match les
amis tangent la prochaine fois on vient
diminuer un bas on n'a pas besoin d'eux
on n'a pas besoin d'être aussi fort
contre c'est la deuxième saison quand on
les joue tu vois en mai on voit là vous
venez même pas tu vois on veut enfin
voilà on a pas besoin
c'est trop facile là tu port d idée
marrante à n ya pas de 8 soit tu voir ce
genre d' inique peut être pas rentrer
mais ça marche pas du tout là enfin
n'importe quoi des fois tu voir kg 5 a
été de faire des matches cinq des huit
morts là c'est enfin c'est pas de facile
de le faire ce que les deux cas sont
contrôlés on les a écrasés on les a
écrasés il va rester plus qu'un match
derrière on ça c'est gagner encore et le
dernier ce sera ambulatoire j'ai un peu
regardé les appariements alors pour le
bullet série chuck n'ai pas énormément
être inscrit donc je remette un lien
faute ou s'inscrire sur le bullet info
se réinscrire il en reste un dernier
ce serait bien de le remettre 3 0 même
si on n'est pas sous pression face on
finira devant le enfin là ils font ils
vont finir dernier c'est sur c'est écrit
c'est vérifiable
donc on est on est on est tranquille un
mais mais ce serait bien leur un poil
plus de monde histoire de tu vois finir
le taf proprement parce qu'ils sont
favoris pour le monde pour les derniers
ce qui est un peu dommage
sans vraiment être grave non plus quoi
sans vraiment un grave non plus à tours
vient ça me parait pénible en fait je
pense que je refasse damage froid pour
venir colmater tout ça il ya ça aussi
mais bien joué j'avais pas vu c'est dur
pour celle de bay cela il a réussi à
trouver un placement de caisse pas
mauvais attendez qu'on le défende g7
hockey à ça et m'a fait un petit échec
et machart et élégant
angers troyes damien roy de kelkoo il
garde les tours
niall curatif il là ça m'inquiète un peu
le piment m'inquiète moi mais le crash
m'inquiète c'est plein des voix
pour bien ça m'inquiète aussi j'ai
plutôt essayé d'échanger là j'ai peur
que qui ait plus d'activités
bon allez faut venir il faut venir jouer
le dernier tournoi les mecs
j'arrive une petite seconde
j'arrive en une petite seconde sa soirée
la partie pour accueillir la petite
pause d'une minute
alors un petit truc et j'arrive
il faut le faire cuire
bizarre ce truc je n'ai jamais goûté
c'est du foie de morue
non mais je crois que c'est ça mais
disent que c'est bon pour la santé mais
c'est tellement bizarre quand vous mais
j'étais très curieux mais c'est très
étrange de mou je crois que j'aime pas
mais je suis pas sûr je sais pas si les
gens dans le chat aime ou pas moi je
crois que j'aime pas j'ai pas si j'aime
ou pas toi tu aimes à la consistance et
un peu bizarre mais quelqu'un dit que
c'est un fake c'est très mauvais dans le
tchat
moi je sais pas si j'aime ou pas c'est
bizarre
sûrement je n'aime pas non je pense que
j'aime pas non plus mais c'était
surprenant comme vous veillez c'est très
bon pour la santé je crois ta première
fois de ma vie que j'ai mangé ça
cette baisse qui a perdu donc il reste
plus qu'un match c'est pas nul hein
c'est juste du foie de morue point bas
rhin bon on n'est pas du tout favori du
bullet
l'une c'est pire encore ouais mais je
pense je pense que lui ça a été horrible
quoi mais ça j'ai jamais mangé j'ai
jamais jamais mangé
wes plus qu'un match à regarder
on va voir on va voir enfin nous
félicitent pour d'avoir joué le tournoi
en fait je lisais les félicitations
on nous a félicités d'avoir participé
donc allez on est parti pour le bullet
qu'est-ce qu'on suis allé on regarde
bien envie de regarder la partie de je
suis triste donc c'est du 2 + 1 il va
falloir faire le taf n'est pas 3 0
serait une bonne nouvelle
on est quand même plus fort derrière
suis en train de regarder un peu les
appariements on devine bien derrière et
c'est devant qu'on est mal mais il ya
déjà une partie qui est fini commence et
finit h quatre des cinq gains pour notre
joueur bon intéressant comme partie du
tracé h4 il a pris des cinq si vous
voulez jouer g4 donc il ya déjà 1 0 2 0
comment on commence à marquer je suis
triste j'ai pas trop ce qui se passe ce
qui va prendre ses quatre essais
prendront eux quatre oui s'ils agissent
faire fois deux modestes et après jouer
avec rock et met la pression mais
j'aurais peut-être fait foi de modeste
c'est quand l'arenas à 21h berra l'eau
vers l'équipe à qui doit pas être un
habitué de la chaîne tension vert allô
t'es habitués dans un monte plus
habitués que faire je met un peu de
crimes talent quand même devant sa moye
c'est aussi intéressant que tyson
française grippale en une minute ont bu
la type e la coller à mach un peu la
colle et ses prix qu'elle prend 1,4 je
suis triste il va prendre mais avoir des
trois échecs roi champions prend à eux
deux prises de 2 cm et c'est peut-être
pas si grave ces trois bon peut-être fou
c'est en recul sait rien des trois-rois
h 1 puis on prend dame prend d ok ça
joue mais j'aurais pas pris je ne dois
pas me faire prendre le fou de cases
noires me serais dit qu'il serait utile
celui-là
peut-être si l'autre fait petit rock
joue avec 4,5 se libérer le x 2 allait
attaquer comme un fou le roi est
peut-être cinq quand même pour amener la
dame verger 5 et attaquer avec le futur
je veux libérer le fou j'aurais fait f5
amd qui est assez rare mais je pense
bien qu'il va la jouer l'aréna nouvelle
c'est bien qu'il la joue c'est marrant
ça fait ça fait plus de joueurs c'est
plus marrant surtout si l écart ou aussi
ça va être drôle mais la reina qui est
super forte ce soir et nous on va partir
avec du retard
ça va vraiment être compliqué et
compliqué hein j'aurais pas le j'aurais
pas vraiment le temps de manger non plus
donc ça va être dur prennent c'est que
si on prend trop de retard c'est un
problème et vous prend au cices ok ça a
commencé par f5 qui veut récupérer à 3
je vois qu'un parti comme ça mais bon il
fait comme il le sent
alors le score de notre tournoi est
toujours 4 2 une vague de parti qui va
se finir en même temps j'imagine 7 3 on
prend on prend on prend on prend le
dessus on peut on peut gagner ce match
on peut gagner ce match mal en bullet où
on est un peu moins bien j'ai un peu
peur pour je suis triste parce que le
pion à moi il me fait super peur il fait
super peur ce pion avec les d4 faut
échanger a laissé bien cryptage la
samouraï qu'est ce que ça donne avec le
talent qui est une calèche de plus mais
faut faire gasc de samouraï qui arnaque
bien donc c'est pas fait mais sexy
cristal il ya une celle là si on peut ne
pas se faire prendre devant si vous
voulez arias est à ya dix sept ils
reviennent ni remonte à les marches
avant eux 4 5 ha et marche avant tour 3
il va faire pousser un an
il trouve du contre j'aurai mais c'est
un grand maître des grands maîtres
trouve toujours du contre je il faut
remettre la tour en 1 c'est pas grave et
avant et envoyé le pion autour des 4 as
il faut gérer le fou qui va se faire
enfermer qui est étrange et 5e ce qui
serait de cette tour des limites c'est
fini mais il change de la tour et ça
c'est très simple à gagner là avec une
seconde par tour
zéro risque rip talent qui gagne partie
importante pas se faire dominer devant
c'est hyper hyper hyper important on est
bien on est bien les mecs sérieusement
on est bien 14/11 faut continuer à tenir
devant et on se fait un peu matraquer en
milieu de tableau mais on devine devant
ta deuxième partie donc continuer à
dominer là on continue à dominer ses
biens faut vraiment gagner ce match
mais ce serait mettre d'être les
premiers à perdre un mini match contre
quoi franchement ce serait ultra dommage
quoi perdre le prêt après 1er mai la
première fois contre franchement ce
serait écoeurant franchement ce serait
écoeurant même méga écoeurant ok il ya
21 11
là on fait les cas on est en train de
faire l'écart les mecs on a un petit
moment difficile en train de se relever
et talc et peut-être bien en plus allez
encore 1,2212 il reste il reste pas mal
de parties en plus ça de vrai
honnêtement ça devrait le faire
ça devrait le faire les amis à elle
c'est cool c'est cool de pas de peur de
ne pas être la première équipe à perdre
contre eux ça fait quand même plaisir on
aurait pu être les premiers à perdre
franchement ça m'aurait sous les viaducs
ont pu sont leurs mets 3 0 on fait comme
les autres
mais peut-être d'alger 3 à tous
resteront intermédiaire ok il faut pas
faire d'un match 4 et y'aura dame prend
des quatre dames prend un ça va
je me demande même si j'aurais pas aimé
reprendre en fuite
moi j'ai peut-être pris la fuite en fait
il fait kg 4 j'ai peut-être pris la
fuite pour maintenir la menace d'un
prend des quatre hockey damev de saïda
me prends des quatre ici qui m'a hyper
fort savannah ces carrières deux échecs
sont menacés dame prend 1 à mais il ya
peut-être et peut-être fou g7
ok mais là je pense qu'il est bien un
creep talent
bonjour 24 13 la dame b2 peut-être
enfermement de de tout cas idée de
probables ont meilleur goût d'affaires
d'à me prends des deux écrites a et voit
la taille qui met 2 0 à la samouraï la
samouraï en sueur la samouraï qui aura
toute la saison n'est cette équipe de
turquie et qui aura absolument tout
perdu est ce qu'il ya des conclusions à
tirer pour les turcs
des têtes vont tomber en turquie des
têtes de turc des têtes de turcs eux
vont tomber alors les a on les écrase
on les écrase les amis on les écrase on
les écrase des têtes de turcs eux vont
tomber ce soir pas passer une saison
comme ça
mais c'est excellent il ya 30 a-15 ya
presque plus de parties 30 à 15 et y
reste il reste peut-être une grosse
dizaine de partis gros nino qui est là
on va regarder le plus petit et l'oci
ridm valait mille cent contre contre 700
il faut qu'ils la gagnent aussi
50 seront alloués encore d'affaires
damage 5 et toute la compagnie là ça va
y aller ça va ça va ça va craquer côté
côté turc
on maintient les quinze points d'écart
32 17 allée bim d'un projet 4
il fait tour à schwyz passe à huy sur
d'amfissa tour h7 j'avais pas vu pardon
allez donc c'est bien joué
parfait parfait parfait parfait
elle a poussé deux ou encore plus fort
peut-être vous ces données étaient plus
forts en conquête à 1.166 m'attendent
c'est fini si réd affirmé son point +16
germain a final de pions on ne pourrait
pas fait froid ces six robes et cinq ici
roye b 5 auquel s et finira ses 4o non
droit b4 maintenant moi c4 c4 3 des 4 as
laissé gagner aussi on à +17 maintenant
on les aurait écrasé assez simple à
gagner mais va-t-il la gagner là c'est
mathématiquement finir
depuis déjà un moment surtout par wade 3
no comments newcomen tu fais juste 3 et
23,3 ces deux airois ici et c'est fini
no comments est incroyable et 7,2 best
car c'est une baisse qui va perdre mais
c'est pas grave
le sniper chase qui a gagné et donc 37
21 et ce qu'il reste encore une partie
oui mais qu'arthur turquie va essayer de
faire nul dans cette position et nous on
va on va changer de stream juste après
et filer vers l'aréna avec dix minutes
de retard ça va être hyper dur de faire
top 8
quasiment impossible pas chaud du tout
en plus et donc ce sera sur ma chaîne
switch et je vais tout de suite switcher
en fait après sans faire le design ne
sent rien turturro
je prends mat enfin qui va se prendre le
hilal et noir et la torah 6 à la finul
mais ça fait sa peur quand même
alors tu retour qui permet le match
vannes gagner ce que c'était la dernière
partie oui bon on a gagné 38 22 merci à
tous et toutes ces matches par
communauté moi je suis vers l'aréna
merci à tous ceux qui ont suivi on va
juste changer de chat sur la chaîne
tweet du bitstream je vais mettre un
lien directement et puis on se retrouve
on se retrouve tout de suite si vous
avez qui fait c'est peut-être plus sympa
on s'est peut-être on s'est peut-être
plus plus sur la fin sur sur ces matches
deux communautés
à bientôt à tout de suite les mecs ciao
ciao